i want to remind everybody that  everybody starts with zero followers the  confusion of the one or two stories you  hear about when it happened fast like  instagram or facebook has confused  everybody anybody you've ever met that  made it worked their [ __ ] face off in  2007 i spent eight hours a day going on  twitter and replying to every single  person that mentioned anything about  wine for four years and still nobody  knew who the [ __ ] i was so when i hear  people say hey garyvee loved you in  chicago great talk but gotta tell you  you're wrong and i reply what happened  well i posted on linkedin and nothing  good is happening and then i asked how  long you've been doing it and like well  i've posted twice for the last two weeks  and i reply you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]